diam's ou moi m'a toujours elle m'a
toujours fasciné c'est une pour moi
c'est le plus grand du rap français
jeudi le plus grand exploit parce que
souvent on dit oui mais le rap n'y a pas
assez de nana est tout voilà donc s'il
n'y a pas assez de nanas en tout cas y
en avait eu une mais camille tous les
mecs à l'amande ces diamants alors le
clash cynique et diam's elle était venue
pour le planète rap de cynique et
cynique était en clash à l'époque avec
un garçon qui s'applique is it où il me
semble puisqu'après kizito effet un
autre morceau et et le règlement de
compte en effet par de planète rap et
moi je sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire
et bim ils font ça et c'est vrai que toi
tu te retrouves au milieu donc au milieu
de ça tu sais pas trop ce qui va surtout
se passer par la suite parce que je te
dis les clashs mois autant quand c'est
bien fait en étant celui ci était plutôt
était plutôt bien et est plutôt bien
fait mais tu sais jamais vraiment apple
[Musique]
n'est qu'au micro supplie
ce moment si je les choisis c'est parce
que voilà j'ai un jet à respect éternel
pour dire me diane j'ai eu la chance en
plus deux en 2006 en 2006 de la suivre
sur la confection de son album dans ma
bulle quand elle a fait quand il a
commencé sa grosse tournée de concerts
qui a duré plus d'un an je me serais
toujours j'étais avec elle quand elle
revient chez elle à l'époque qu'elle
habitait dans 14e à paris et on monte
chez elle et et hamdi ben voilà en fait
tu sors d'une d'une tournée tu avais été
vu trois cent mille quatre cent mille
spectateurs j'en sais rien je sais
certainement beaucoup plus mais t'as pas
c'est grosso modo un nom de ta vie sur
la route avec away près peut-être d'un
million de spectateurs en tout cas de
qui sont venus de voir et tu te
retrouves dans ta chambre chez toi tout
seul quoi et c'est vrai que ça j'ai vu
rarement auprès d'artistes mais je l'a
vu avec mélanie j'ai vu avec diam's et
tu peux comprendre aussi que c'est un
c'est quelque chose voilà pas forcément
évident à vivre
[Musique]
alors c'est aussi pareil sazy fait
partie pour moi des artistes qui sont
absolument extraordinaires
zhu le sait il a eu raison d'appeler ses
projets l'ovni c'est un ovni et c'est
surtout que je me suis même d'ailleurs
au début beaucoup de gens critiquaient
jul en soi mais auto tune à part ça aide
mais douce qui nous a prouvé c'est que
c'est un [__] de kicker quoi et ça
j'ai eu la chance de le voir assez vite
et c'est pour ça que j'étais toujours
halluciné quand en corrigeant critiquer
de joueurs aux méduses ou machine hôte
au dessus moi j'ai toujours vu alors
bien sûr qui fait des morceaux avec auto
tune n'est pas que moi quand je vois jul
je le vois kike et c'est vrai qu'il
détient un record actuellement dans
planète rap on avait instauré un record
je tiens à préciser un record vidéo
parce que ça nous était beaucoup
reproché donc là ça a été 43 minutes et
3 secondes ou une seconde en 43 minutes
et une seconde ils sont le record de jul
et ce record là il l'a fait en cliquant
sans auto tune sans rien pendant 43
minutes
dubois qui vient de battre le record
[Musique]
on sait clairement celui qui est celui
qui bosse le plus c'est planète rap
en quelques années il nous a délivré si
jeune si tu prends tous les albums
inédits dont il en sort aussi des
gratuits mais à planète rap quand il
vient faire un planète rap il fait les
albums inédits planète rap ou pendant
une semaine tu vas te retrouver au bout
de la semaine avec 10 12 voir plus de
morceaux inédits de jul quoi tu imagines
pour pour nous pour l'émission pour les
gens si pour les auditeurs la chance que
c'est d'avoir un job c'est quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai un énorme respect
talentueux et voilà que j'apprécie pas
qu'à moitié
[Musique]
l'homme parle il ya des moments comme ça
qu'ils sont extraordinaires tu as un
moment où il vient un jour avec philippe
katerine dans l'émission et où tu as
aussi à la capote et je me suis toujours
de ce moment irait déjà août à philippe
katerine qui est quand même un
personnage en lui-même quoique un
personnage et puis talent capote qui est
juste en face et à philippe katerine qui
commence à faire son truc et à la capote
qui fait le plus petit budget
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs c'est ça aussi pareil
philippe katerine moi je me suis encore
et toujours quand ils sortent du planète
rap et que je discute de seconde avec
lui me regarde donc je pense que
philippe katerine a vu beaucoup de
choses dans sa vie
je pense que j'ai rien à apprendre à
philippe katerine il me regarde il dit
mais ton émission c'est comme ça tous
les soirs où ils avaient leurs deuxième
et ça existe encore c'est genre
d'émission où il peut y avoir tout et
n'importe quoi où tu entendes plus de
pub d'un seul coup pendant qu'un
chanteur de variétés chambre et je dis
bah ouais c'est tous les soirs il était
assez halluciné là-dessus et c'est vrai
qu'elle clame pas le voilà l'autre grand
souvenir c'est conséquent tout le monde
le porte d'un seul coup je me retrouve
sur élevé si tu veux et je tiens quand
même à dire que je souhaiterais mon
petit point j'ai arrêté le sport en 6e
peut-être avant donc voilà je vous je
vole littéralement dans mon studio je
suis portée par les gars et je vis un
moment que ça soit je n'aurais jamais
vécu de ma vie mais mon concert j'ai
jamais aimé que ça c'est dans planète
rap deux filles anne so pour la sortie
du projet devienne saut et sofiane
m'avait déjà parlé m'avait fait écouter
mutins mais là y'a un mec
bon il a déjà sa carrière et fait déjà
des trucs il est sur marseille mais bien
d'alger et bien d'algérie machin c'est
soul king et tout et je te le ramène ce
soir tu vas voir le mec c'est un fait
moi c'est un tueur et c'est un tueur il
sait chanter c'est râpé il a un truc
avec son corps parce que comme il était
danseur tu as une façon aussi de bouger
et s'est dit tu vas voir ce gars il est
il est bluffant et l'atteinte à la voix
de soul king et guérillas le morceau
guérilla qui commence à raisonner
commence à faire son morceau et
déjà tu sens parce que le planète rap
parfois être très agitées peut se calmer
d'un seul coup donc tu sens si tu veux
que là il ya une écoute et qu'en même
temps sa part aussi été yam il ya plein
de gens qui suivent le gars où tu sens
qu'il arrive à focaliser tous les
regards sur lui d'un seul coup pendant
ce planète rap je chante un mort au
milieu d'eux banias
parce que je tiendrais pour toujours mon
âge est en balance la vidéo sur sur sur
la chaîne youtube de skyrock ou un
million de millions 1,3 me et même
d'ailleurs moi au début j'ai dit à
l'équipe ché mais qu'est ce que c'est me
paye début je sais pas c'est quoi allez
vous pouvez me dire d'où ça vient c'est
pas possible ce que même si j'aurais ça
bon je faisais de l'aca monde tellement
vite j'ai jamais vu monter autant et
aussi rapidement bon je déposerai
premier passage à 100 millions 150
millions je crois qu'on à 260 larouche
te parle on doit être à 270 millions il
me semble alors là on est en 2009
et pareil donc cette fois ci on sait pas
lui-même qui vient c'est moi qui vais
vers si tu ne viens pas si tu ne vas pas
eminem eminem viendra à toi et
inversement
ben là c'est moi qui écrivais direction
les états unis à détroit et des preuves
quand même dire que c'est quand même pas
la ville la plus agréable des états unis
honnêtement alors tu as toujours
forcément des quartiers qui sont plutôt
mignon mais détroit une vie très pauvre
tu sens à d'ailleurs tu sens une ville
dure donc tu es aussi plonger dans ce
climat je sais aussi que j'arrive dans
un contexte particulier parce que eminem
a eu tous les succès à hub est justement
le film et mary-kate un carton et
sortait d'une dépression il sortait de
deux moments pénibles
et finalement vaines interview était
assez irréel ce moment là c'était un
moment assez vrai parce que je
m'attendais à voir justement eminem peut
chanter aussi meurtri parce qu'ils ne
perdent aussi un de ses potes qui
s'appelle proof qui faisait partie du
groupe dit web avec lui donc
et puis finalement non ça a été un bon
moment je devais faire par une fois de
plus 15 minutes et on a traîné un peu
plus 20 30 40 minutes où on voit là où
il ya eu il ya eu un vrai échange est un
vrai moment de bonheur